everyone knows how to win but only a few
know how to lose and I say this because
recently we had a loss and that loss was
we announced the second week of May that
we wanted to have a hundred thousand
subs by August 31st and remember when we
announced that we had about 41,000 subs
when it ended we did not hit a hundred
thousand subs we ended with 83 thousand
subs and it was very disappointing we
were very annoyed we were very
frustrated that we didn't hit the
hundred thousand subs and then somebody
asked a question on the YouTube channel
on the bottom and said you know what Pat
I would really want to know how you
handle a loss and I said what a great
idea to do an episode on how to handle
loss because so many times everybody
talked about doing and motivating all
this other stuff but how do you handle a
loss so today's episode gonna be all
about that a matter of fact it was so
painful that Mario from the team is
still emotional with the fact that we
didn't hit a hundred thousand subs Paul
want you show Mario's reaction here a
little bit on how emotionally is are you
gonna be okay you sure all right Mari is
going to be okay maybe you can let me
see this up here real quick but if you
haven't sub to my favor and subscribe to
the channel okay here you go Mario
there's the love okay so now how do we
handle a loss as an entrepreneur okay
there's three things i'll cover here
today one is two different types of
goals people said to is what do you do
when you actually set up a goal and then
three is how to handle loss and how do
you debrief when you don't achieve your
goal so we'll cover those three things
but let me start off with the first one
what do I mean by there are two
different types of goals okay so there
are people that set too small of a goal
or too big of a goal so what is too
small of a goal unfortunately there are
a lot of people that most of their goals
become a reality most of the goals
become a reality and what I mean by that
the goal could be hey I want to have a
job they land a job hey I want to have a
place to live they get a place to live
hey I want to have three square meals to
eat every day they get those meals I
want to have a car to drive they get a
car I want to one day get married they
get married everything is they hit a
goal but it's small of a goal and they
settle so their goals become a reality
but it's too small of a goal then
the complete opposite is people who set
way way too ambitious goals with small
timelines let me explain for instance I
remember I got out of the army I was 21
years old I have a picture of this that
I took and if we were back at home you
know back in Dallas we would show this
year but I'm back at home and I would
have shown the picture I have a blue
shirt polyester shirt pretty pathetic
I'm wearing a blue polyester shirt I
used to dress like my inspiration was
John Travolta from Saturday Night Fever
and stayin alive so I have this shirt
and I'm holding the paper and I'm in
Chicago with two of my friends and on it
it says when I'm gonna be a millionaire
and my date for becoming a millionaire
was a year after getting out of the army
now how am I gonna become a millionaire
you have to getting out of the army
where I know nothing how to do anything
right I knew nothing right and I want to
be a millionaire within a year didn't
happen disappointed some people want to
get married find a loved one and have a
kid within a week unless if you marry
somebody with a kid that is way too
ambitious of a goal right or you say I
want to be a billionaire within the next
two years I get it and I want you to
know sometimes people say well Pat isn't
it good to think big it is very good to
think big but that goal must be a goal
that if a hundred percent it's
impossible for you to hit it and zero is
you're guaranteed to hit it
make sure it's 80% that makes any sense
make sure it's 80% so what do I mean by
that you got two thousand dollars in
savings right now your goal is to have a
hundred thousand dollars in savings
within 18 months I like that you're 168
pounds right now you want to get to 148
pounds lose 20 pounds in next 60 days
that's good if you say I want to lose 20
pounds in a week that's not healthy to
do that but if you say within a month or
two okay that's good you can pull that
off if you drop the certain things
attitude you can get to that weight so
again to two types of goals too small of
a goal too big of a goal you want to
make sure you set a goal that is
reachable but it's got to be difficult
to reach it's got to be difficult to
reach yet you can reach it so you'll
kind of get that part when you do more
of these things you'll eventually figure
out and remember there isn't just like
in the world of sports
no basketball teams ever gone undefeated
the greatest basketball player of all
time is Michael Jordan any miss 45% of
his shots and he lost quite a lot of
games
he wasn't undefeated the greatest
baseball player of all time was Babe
Ruth he had three out of ten times if
you think about it ten not bad so don't
expect undefeated and perfection okay
but at the same time you need to be
getting your hits you need to be getting
your victories you need to be getting
your shots you need to be scoring and
winning so make sure you know exactly
how to do that part with your size your
goal so now let's go to the next part
next part is okay now what do I do now
so let's talk about the process of
setting a goal number one number one you
set a goal now what is a goal what is
the goal tied to a lot of people have a
goal generally to me when I think about
a goal I think about a number so what's
a goal goal is I want to lose 20 pounds
goal is I want to make a hundred
thousand goal is I want to have five
thousand subs on my youtube channel goal
is I want to do you know have fifty
thousand dollars in savings goal is tied
to a number goal is tied to a number
goal is generally tied to a number so
you set a goal and a number so you write
those two down whatever that thing is
number one goal number so just write
this down and go with me number two is
your strategy on how to get there
so goal number strategy how to get there
I know Paul's typing it here so you kind
of seen it on the screen there's also a
goal number strategy how to get there
you got to take a minute and write out a
strategy on how you're gonna get to the
number number three is there's got to be
a deadline goals without deadlines mean
nothing sometimes people say I want to
be a millionaire but there's no deadline
you're not going to be a millionaire
you're just winging it I want to lose 20
pounds by when I want to make six
figures by when I want to have $50,000
in savings by when I want to buy my
house by when deadline deadline is very
very critical so so far we have what
goal number strategy then you have your
deadline the next thing next thing I
call your ask your value meaning what
are you asking for the goal and what
value you're going to bring for that
goal what are you exchanging your ask
for your value here's what I want this
is the value I'm willing to bring to
make a hundred thousand dollars this is
the value I'm willing to bring to buy my
house this is the value I'm willing to
bring
to say $50,000 this is the value I'm
going to bring for me to lose 20 pounds
what's the value I'm willing to go to
the gym four times a week this is the
value I'm willing to bring to make the
specs and value almost means like how
are you going to improve yourself that's
what I take value as so what areas are
going to proven yourself areas of
improvement disciplines etc etc habits
so now we have goal number strategy goal
number strategy deadline your ask your
value next one is declaring your
intention here's what I mean by
declaring your intention there's a big
difference between you having a personal
trainer that you hire then you working
about yourself here's why if he says you
got to be that six o'clock in the
morning and you're late by five minutes
there's two things that happens in your
mind one you're saying I'm paying 150
bucks an hour and I'm late five minutes
I just lost 10 bucks that's what you
tell yourself - here's what you say man
I don't want to be late because I'm
wasting his time he's going to think I'm
not serious accountability so that's
declaring your intention when you say
when you say you want to do something
you got to tell the world about it the
world holds you accountable the world
holds you accountable a lot of people
want to get in shape but they're afraid
of saying what they look like today hold
yourself accountable you'd be amazed on
how much that positive pressure can get
you to do something in yourself you know
hey what is your intentions this year
what we're playing this year to win the
Superbowl and we're doing everything we
can to get to the big show we're doing
everything we can to get to the big show
you know what's important to us we're
going after the big show and you'll see
the difference between how NBA players
sometimes they'll say do you think if
you finish your curry without
championships you think your legacy is
still intact yes okay then that's not
their goal now you see somebody else
saying you think your career intact if
you don't want any championship - no I
have to win a championship
that's declaring intention then you got
to go get it and fans they love it and
there's pressure then you practice you
train harder because you got to make
sure you come to come through and the
last one is execution period so now you
have your goals and your numbers your
strategy which is your how-to your
deadline which is clear on when you want
to hit it and I typically deadlines to
me I like 90-day deadlines I'm a 90-day
type of guy I know a lot of times we can
do thirty days or one week and you know
what am I going to do this week you
always have your days and your weeks on
Sunday nights I would prepare for my
to our week but say this is a 90 day go
we're talking about you have a deadline
then it's your ask your value your ask
your value and then you declare your
intention and its execution okay so we
said now on what happens with that now
let's talk about the complete ourselves
what we did and then what you don't do
when you come back so now for us it was
our goal the number was what a hundred
thousand subs was what we wanted to do
right our strategy was we were going to
produce one video which was called good
voice bad voice which on Facebook it did
very well and then ended up getting 1.1
million views and I think on YouTube it
ended up getting 96 thousand views or
something like that okay so that was one
of our strategies and our strategy was
our two videos a week that we were doing
and with the hopes of that the following
every video we were going to execute and
say hey please subscribe and please
invite other people to subscribe to the
channel subscribe to the channel help us
out and by the way I want to take a
moment and just thank all of you that
really helped out this channel because
quite frankly we would be at zero subs
if it wasn't for you we wouldn't even be
at 80 80 some thousand subs I think
we're at eighty eighty nine thousand
subs when you're watching this we would
not be if it wasn't for you sharing this
video with other people inviting other
people to join emailing your friends
sharing it on your social media so from
me to you I want to thank you for
helping us out but you heard one part of
our strategy was every single chant
every single video you're going to see
this please subscribe so we made to ask
part of the strategy was make the ask we
brought you the value we ask please will
you subscribe to the channel and we gave
you value ask value ask value ask value
okay so strategy was right there
deadline was August 31st deadline was
August 31st then after the deadline it
was declaring intention which we said it
we said after the deadline is you asked
your value then it's declaring your
intention hey we want to get 200,000
subs by August 31st and then it was
execution okay so now obviously we
didn't execute perfectly because we
didn't get to a hundred thousand subs so
now I've coupled with you two different
types of goals I've covered with you how
to set your own goals now I'm going to
cover with you you did not hit a goal
what do you do now this is exactly what
we did so I'll cover specific details
number
number one number one and the only way
this works if you're brutally honest
with yourself this does not work if you
are not brutally honest with yourself it
only works if you're very honest with
yourself so step number one is
identified the positives let me explain
to what I mean by identify deposits a
lot of times you don't hit a goal and
people say I'm such a loser I'm the
worse on this on that and they just beat
themselves up because they didn't hit a
goal and and and there is a positive in
that but but the other side is what
happened what improvement did take place
so the first thing we did is we sat down
I said guys we did not hit 100,000 subs
you guys know how I feel about this I'm
not happy I think we could done a much
better job but what good did happened
from this and in mario paul the team
started saying things and one of the
things was we started our YouTube
channel November of 2012 okay and we
were winging it for a couple years right
and so it took us three and a half years
to get to 41,000 subscribers in three
and a half years from the moment we
declared our intention 90 days later we
got 42,000 subs so we got 41,000 subs in
three and a half years we got 42,000
subs in 90 days because we had a goal we
had a strategy we had a deadline we had
a year ask yur value we declared our
intention and we try to execute so the
good was we got more subs in 90 days and
we did in three and a half years what
was another victory that we got the
other victory was the fact that we
produce a video good voice bad voice
that did very well was a six minute and
30 second video we did nothing was going
to do that good but it did get a million
plus views on Facebook that was a second
video that got a million plus views for
us with the life of an entrepreneur
getting 28 point I think 28.7 now twenty
point eight not whatever the amount of
views it is so that was a success that
was a positive so the first thing you
got to do is identify your positives now
the next thing to too is my favorite one
identify your leaks identify your leaks
these are the leaks that we found we
found the leaks that we only do two
videos a week so we do two Tuesdays and
Thursdays if we do two videos a week it
doesn't give the audience doesn't get
exposed to value tainment
Friday Saturday Sunday Wednesday Monday
and so
you are asking for more content per week
instead of just two I just don't have
the time to always do it but I love some
of the feedback that you guys gave which
was great you said Pat can you do more
videos with just simply grabbing your
phone and telling us your experience and
given some value and I said any I can do
that so you know I just grabbed the
phone and started doing a couple
episodes and many of you said these are
my favorite videos I did a video called
the the the greatest compensation plan
which was with the kids and the family
and the lego either one out of the
restaurant I did another one I don't
know where I did the other one from the
one we do with the restaurant of the the
oyster place so you know this the the
leak we could have done more of those we
didn't do that okay that's one we didn't
do any collaboration we did no
interviews we interview very well every
time we do interviews it does very very
well I don't know a single interview
we've done that hasn't done well and
brought a lot of audience to the channel
we didn't do it we're going to do more
of that in the future reaching out to
our own network in our context we have
thousands of messages that we haven't
yet gone back to and these are people
that want to do podcasts and all these
other things that we haven't done with
the moment we identify these leaks and
using our available tools so the moment
we identify these leaks we made
immediate adjustments we got on podcast
with John Lee Dumas with Amy Porterfield
and now I'm in Harvard Business School
right now as we speak you know three
weeks I'm here with people sitting to my
left one is worth you know a billion the
other one is I can't say who these
people are but you would know their
names I'm in a classroom with them and
we can have some exciting things that's
going to come from here I'm speaking at
Texas A&M I'm going to be in New York
later on this week in New York then I'm
pitching something next which is massive
there's so many things that are going to
be coming out soon that helps with this
but because we identified our leaks we
knew what areas to improve in step
number three rank your strategy we have
to rank our strategy was our strategy a
good strategy between 0 to 10 I give our
strategy that we have to get 200,000
subs of 5 is what we had as our strategy
we could have come up with a better
strategy than anything else and I take
full responsibility for myself because
I'm the I'm the leader here so I need to
take responsibility
the strategy we could have done a much
better job with the strategy we put
together to get 200,000 subs and you as
a leader you need to be honest with
yourself and take responsibility if your
strategy was my best strategy number
four how do you rank your level of
execution I think for what we had our
strategy our level of execution was fine
because it was a reflection of the
strategy and because the strategy was so
weak we executed a very weak strategy
that got us 42,000 subscribers that
makes any sense then the next thing is
how would you rank your effort from the
beginning to the end
I thought our effort for our strategy
was good could we have gone above and
beyond yes because the team got a little
bit more innovative yes could there have
been something that we were more
efficient yes but how do you rank your
effort on what you did we would probably
give it a 7 on the effort and then 6 how
urgent were you how urgent were you a
lot of times you know when you're
setting a goal I think people either
come at the gates quick and if they
don't get any response that they wanted
they slow down and shut down and they
forget about their goal or they don't
come out the gate strong and I call
these guys mellows because you know Melo
Carmelo Anthony is known for playing
fourth quarter but he doesn't play three
quarters and in all of us anyone's ever
come back in the fourth quarter and
plays his heart out what if you play
like that from first quarter right and
so you know they panic and then you know
it's like the person that there's a
homework last minute type of thing where
you have two weeks to finish your
homework but you do a last minute we
need to start it at the beginning so you
don't have to do last minute so those
are ways you assess your goals so quick
recap one goals you said too small of a
goal or do you said too big of a goal
and how can you make adjustments and
your goals in that area to what is the
process of goal-setting let me see if I
remember this vividly number one was
goal goal is tied to number number two
is deadline
number two is deadline number three is
your ask your why I think is number
three number now I'm missing one of no
number one is goal numbers number two a
strategy how number three is deadline
number four is your ask your value
number five is declaring your intention
and a number six is your execution and
then at the end is finding
don't hit your goal what things to do
and it's six steps number one identify
the positives identify the league's how
do you rank your strategy how do you
rank your level of execution how would
you rank your effort from beginning to
the end and how urgent were you and if
you take that approach with your goals
you will start seeing better results
because it's all about improvement and
again I don't know your work ethic
I don't know how hard you work I can
tell you our team is a very very hard
working team I put our work ethic
against anybody else I put our work
ethic against anybody else in the
marketplace on how well we work but you
got to make sure your work ethic is
there as well then comes the
goal-setting strategy that you put in
place now that you got some value this
is when I give my ask and my ask is I am
asking you to subscribe to this channel
and help us get 200,000 subs and then
after that we got to get 2 million subs
together so for those you guys that are
helping us out thank you so much for
those me that are just subscribers help
us get this channel to other people
somebody said the other day this channel
is the Khan Academy for entrepreneurs
because YouTube is not filled with many
channels that do how-tos
this is why we believe we have the best
channel on YouTube for entrepreneurs
pound-for-pound we feel we can go with
anybody on the subject of
entrepreneurship so with that being said
if you got any questions about what I
talked about with goal-setting comment
on the bottom again if you haven't sub
please do so if you're watching this
video on a complete different website
you can always come back to Patrick with
David calm and boldly is that a new
feature Paul you added that was a
request though is that the request from
the arsy a88 for guy yes no it was RZA
recite a force like a would we take a
client type of thing isn't it if it's
related for because that's a sign for
wu-tang clan let us know cuz I know you
said I don't want the three things I
want to have an explosion with the great
climax or whatever so that was dedicated
to you but anyways
with that being said again comment on
the bottom if you got any questions and
thanks for watching take care bye bye